hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from round seven of the 44th
chess Olympiad on the white end Wesley
so and he's paired against front
malcumian USA versus Armenia
Wesley so comes up with a brilliant
tactical idea that is in my opinion a
must-see
so let's hop right to this game
we have a Carroll Khan defense
the game lasts 28 moves about half of it
is a whole lot of simple development or
the repositioning of pieces to better
squares
eventually though things heat up in the
center there will be tension and where
there's tension there's often a tactic
we have a pin
black is prepared to give up Bishop for
night we have this imbalance five Moves
In Black now without a light Square
Bishop compensates for it by putting
pawns on light
this is the main Pawn to reinforce the
furthest Advanced Pond strongest Pawn
it's rock solid
there is one positional detail I'd like
to draw attention to in this game
and it involves this tension in the
timing
of its release
uh when
is the move e captures D played
is now the time
no Bishop B2
Bishop C5
is now the time no castles Knight D7
follows are we there yet we're there it
is on this movie that white captures on
D5 black recaptures towards the center
why did white wait
well
there is a relationship here between
these pawns this tension and the queen
Knight
it is only after the queen Knight has
made the commitment to D7 that white
makes this capture
it is only after the queen Knight has
gone to D7 that white opens up we might
say
the C6 Square
now this Knight can't get to its
favorite post so easily
if white isn't patient let's say instead
of castles chops here right now
and then castles you think this guy's
going here nope
black would already be better
this is a big deal
what it's coming down to
is that
with white being a little patient
with this capture
further into this game black will have
to invest
too tempy in order to
have this Knight function well
it's a big deal
okay
a little bit of patience goes a long way
we might say
all right from here Rook D1 white would
like a pawn in the center
gets just that this is not just about
I wanna threaten a bishop no
this Pawn on D4 is holding up this guy
from maybe advancing black after all has
a central majority
what else is the Pawn on D4 doing is
controlling this
it's unfortunate but yeah that second
ranked Knight is now under control
doesn't really want to be there
and it's under control
okay repositioning Bishop now
on a much better diagonal
castles Bishop F4 Knight to B8 why are
you going home
because you're terrible on D7 okay here
are the two Tempi I was referring to
Knight goes back home
92
Knight C6 black now has the queen Knight
on a better Square
and is a blink away from challenging the
unopposed light Square Bishop but
because white was timely with the Knight
to E2 the Knight is easily offset and
the center is reinforced
okay
from here rookie eight rookie one
G6
black stays strong on the lights on the
light squares and also there is an idea
potentially to play Knight to H5
I'd like to highlight this one variation
here let me make a
a somewhat standard move you might see
structurally speaking A4 is usually a
good move to get in here
black
black could follow with Knight to H five
and look to eventually trade dark Square
Bishops
um
if the bishop goes off of this diagonal
there's E5
and if it is maintained on this diagonal
well it could be challenged and this
would be a desirable exchange for black
typical
idea here
your opponent has the bishop pair let's
try and get rid of one of them
okay
we don't have A4 here instead
the White Knight improves
and negates any Knight H5
okay the Knight goes elsewhere Knight D7
gearing up potentially for E5 this does
hit this is where things do sharpen
we're now at move 17.
E5 on board
like to draw your attention to a few
different variations right around this
point
Wesley on this move 18
spends about 10 minutes
he ends up playing Bishop to H6
uh that turns out to be not the the best
move black has a good reply to that he
doesn't come up with the best reply
we have a case here where there are a
couple back-to-back issues
first thing to have a look at here is
what would happen if white simply
captured on E5
well black would be able to play Bishop
C5 a newly weakened Square after the
after d takes E5 this is opened up
and this gains a valuable Tempo Against
The Rook
um while also adding what is now a third
attacker to E5
so considered best from here is E6 and
some Rook exchange and a somewhat
balanced position from here the Knight
on G3
is not so great here
okay
that's one variation to note
let's have a look at the move in the
game Bishop to H6
this is almost
in a way
um
baiting
black to push forward with E4 this is
the move that was played in the game and
it's a big blunder
uh this
this move was played only after about a
minute so this one took 10 minutes this
is where Wesley did
some serious calculation here with
Bishop to H6 even though it isn't and
this this bishop H6 move isn't quite the
best but he knew when he played Bishop
to H6 that this E4 move would not be
good for black he did some deep
calculation here
uh before I show this move in the game
what is considered best for black is to
immediately challenge this guy we'll see
why this is so important to try and get
rid of the dark Square control let's say
of G7 and f8
um
the idea of being to meet Bishop takes
Bishop with only then E4 and it says
that black here is in the driver's seat
I'm not going to go any further than
this
let's get on with this amazing
uh This brilliant tactical idea that
Wesley has
how tempting it is
black ended up playing Pawn to E4 so
I'll now throw it to you as a pop quiz
what is This brilliant idea that Wesley
had
feel free to pause the video what is the
best move for white
okay here we go
best move winning move
is Rook takes E4
um
that came as a great shock to Black No
Doubt because he was essentially rocked
back in his seat and he thought about
his next move for a half an hour
E4 took one minute and his reply to Rook
takes E4
a half hour so he clearly missed
something
uh Black's reply in this game is Knight
to f8 but what could have been
if Pond captures Rook this is what
Wesley
had calculated
if the Rook is captured it is
I'll throw it to you as a pop quiz what
would be the continuation from here feel
free to pause the video
okay let's get on with it
we would have this beautiful queen
sacrifice on F7
king h8 would just be mate
so you have to take the queen
this is
this is a mate in six
chop chop and everything is forced
every every move for black isn't only
move I should say
Bishop C4 would follow the king is
getting pulled closer to the white side
Knight takes E4 only move
G4 only move Rook E1
only move
and the final blow here
white actually has an option
you could play
well not that move you could play Rook
E3 for me or
for whatever the reason
I don't know I like this one better
with the Bishops
um
crisscrossing here what a finish this
would have been
this is something that uh you know you'd
see old school games romantic style
chess the king being pulled all the way
to one of the games I'm thinking of
is one where there was like castles or a
king move for checkmate King gets pulled
right down into your camp
this is really wild this is uh part of
what makes chess so awesome it is not
just the moves that are actually played
in the game but the ideas behind certain
uh certain
tactics certain tricks here this Rook
takes E4 or even going further back
Bishop H6 before you play Bishop H6 you
have to know what you're doing reply to
E4
if you don't play Rook takes E4 here
you're you're losing
or at least black is in the driver's
seat here
so this had to all be worked out here
very good eye by Wesley so in this game
right here after uh seeing this this
idea of the queen sack on F7
okay Rook takes E4 half hour spent here
ends up playing Knight to f8 White is
now simply up a pawn
that's a big Pawn so Rook F4 follows the
rest of the game really isn't so uh
interesting
white is prepared to give up the night
on G3 takes out two pawns white
continues with the attack here
attacking for free essentially
the imbalance now is three pawns versus
a minor piece but this this king is
stripped of its defenses
play follows with Queen D6
Queen G4
yeah King in the corner it's mate
uh the Knight has to block if
the queen goes here there's Rook takes
Knight and then the queen Falls
so Knight G6 Rook takes D5 this Rook is
really uh teasing black here you can't
really take the take the rook in this
position either he couldn't take it when
it was on e4 or in this case when it's
on D5
in the game Queen F6 is played
if Queen takes Rook they would follow
Bishop takes Knight White's crashing
through mate next
okay so in the game it is Queen F6
and now some defensive move I guess
we're boxing out the night we're
not allowing maybe a queen exchange on
H4
controlling move additional point you
have a flight Square
from here Bishop f8
Rook F5 Queen E7 now the bishop gets to
land this check
King h8
Bishop G5 that's the final move of the
game
black resigns
no good solution here I'll touch on a
couple variations one is Queen D6 you
could have Rook F6
Queen C7 Rook F7
and next up Bishop F6 is Really Gonna
Hurt
especially since uh the bishop won't be
able to interpose now that the Rook is
on that square
and these Bishops will be functioning
really well on adjacent diagonals
and one final variation
I guess would be this one here if Queen
E4 in this position
that will be met
really well with Rook takes Bishop
Rook takes Rook Queen takes Queen
and if Knight takes Rook
once more we have these killer Bishops
lokai Bishop G5 was the final move to
this one and yeah in my opinion uh a
brilliant tactical idea there by Wesley
so
seeing that follow-up Queen sacrifice on
F7 was really something
so anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye